[Rires]
tu connais fianso
il est là ce soir
ça va
alors tu nous connais pas on arrive
soit on est pas là on va dormir
c'est pas grave
ce soir on n'est pas là on va dormir
chien c'est pas de ma faute à moi si
dans l'eau
ok on y va cette année danger arme à feu
ranger Mario maréchal Dakar et Alger
Bamako Tanger Marion maréchal c'est un
nid d'Angers
est-ce qu'il nous reste du monde ici
bien le bonsoir écrivons comment ça va
j'ai appelé deux trois potes à moi
c'est magique c'est pas moi qui danse
mais je reconnais très je te
reconnaîtrai ça va ça dans un repas dans
une boîte des matins le soleil se lève
pour tout le monde le matin je me lève
le pouvoir si tu essayes de faire tu te
réveilles assez tôt acheter des pas vide
des chargeurs ça détend je suis pas
devenu un loup pour finir en chien
branchement quand la vie nous balance
c'est de la haute couture on assume la
suite je suis de rap de face les
carottes sont cuites personne par deux
meuf personne parle de filtre moitié
Kara des dragons dans mon dos quand toi
tu es pas là la sauce a braqué
Pousse-toi je dois ma chance je te fais
quoi fais-moi là j'ai déjà tout lâché
dans les bras de mon frère cache pas le
nom des morts sans remords tu crames et
regrette une fille et larves de la nôtre
jamais comme les plans d'une femme
bientôt
fait du bruit on fout la merde cher du
son
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a aucune sécurité aujourd'hui
c'est nous la sécu ça fait peur hein
moi je suis avec toi
et Marion maréchal toca c'est le morceau
du clip qui a fait 22 millions de vues
celui ou avec tes potes vous bloquez
l'autoroute A3 c'est comme un tapissage
pour moi c'est le 4 je reconnais
formellement le cadre
alors dis-moi sérieusement quand même
vous avez bloqué l'autoroute A3 le 13
juin au tribunal quand même on va aller
faire un tour on verra mais après
blocage tout est relatifs
Aulnay-sous-Bois 3 semaines plus tard
ouais d'ailleurs c'est un une surprise
pour moi aussi on avait appelé cinq
personnes on se retrouve à 500 3 jours
de garde à vue 8 ans
un très bon maître Ruben le célèbre
maître
déclaration d'amour à Marion Maréchal-Le
Pen quand même non
j'ai dit Marion maréchal tu as dit Le
Pen
je surveille tu touches rien
tu as dit elle a à côté d'où cette meuf
ouais un peu je trouve ouais c'est vrai
on est pas d'accord
tu pourrais la pécho ouais ouais je
pense qu'il y a moyen Marion maréchal
alors vous avez manifesté
vous avez manifesté pour Théo le 11
février 2017 vous avez ramené le calme
fianso en parlementant avec les
policiers le mec t'a dit à moins de 10
mètres je suis obligé de vous allumer
donc tu as dit chacun garde les siens
enfin moi ça a été la chance surtout de
pas tomber sur un imbécile en face
vous arranger mais en revanche
concernant Adama Traoré c'est quand même
beaucoup plus radical quand même on voit
le tweet là l'affaire Adama Traoré
mérite un deuxième novembre 2005 est-ce
que c'est une bonne idée de démarrer un
nouveau novembre 2005 je reconnais que
l'affaire de la Damas Traoré il y a un
problème qui n'est pas résolu et qu'il
va falloir le résoudre entièrement
d'accord avec toi mais est-ce que ça
vaut le coup de démarrer un nouveau
novembre 2005 alors non pas forcément et
en fait faut recadrer faut replacer le
le tweet dans ce dans son contexte tu
vois contexte c'est qu'à ce moment-là ma
parole ma voix n'a pas autant de poids
que maintenant donc oui effectivement en
ce moment là je tweet sur le coup des
nerfs ça m'énerve ça je comprends que ça
t'énerve ça nous touche tous mais
effectivement aujourd'hui je le revois
et avec tout ce qui s'est passé pour moi
actuellement et le poids qui a pris ma
parole effectivement c'est super
maladroit alors c'est quoi les concerts
que tu vas faire là parce que les gens
qui te voient la télé vont aller devoirs
sur scène là c'est quand même
l'autoroute
on est en tournée on est en tourné
depuis quelques mois maintenant
on reprend une grosse tournée en
septembre de toute façon ça sera affiché
sur mes réseaux les réseaux sociaux en
général donc voilà ce qui va venir nous
voir sur scène ils sont grand bienvenus
tout simplement très bien merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu